the gyro can experience well there's
that and then there's that these
communities stay the way they are like
whether it's Baltimore where they had it
set up or black people literally weren't
allowed to buy homes outside of certain
areas or any inner-city like you know in
inner city in Houston or New York or
anywhere where the neighborhood stay the
same
yeah they stay the same generation crime
poverty all the drugs everything stays
the same and I don't you know so my kids
you know I might my kids are [ __ ]
they blessings they don't realize how
blessed they are and sometimes I get so
pissed off at them like they go to this
really nice high school where I live it
in Indiana they get their little laptops
and you know they get new books every
[ __ ] year Joe when I went to school
it was so many nickels named growing in
that same book what it had done checked
it out every year you had to flip a page
and you just see my mom Tyrone's I got
three pages of kids who had that book
and it pisses me off because you know I
look at it and I was like what this is
the old curriculum where you know these
keep my kids are getting a new
curriculum every year and it's still
like that in certain parts of America
and it pisses me off though like yeah
you guys don't realize how blessed you
are you come into a [ __ ] this [ __ ]
thousand dollar pad on the float at this
school and gave you take shift grant
like my daughter would literally hold up
the school bus because she wanted to
walk slow because she was fat so the
lady called me was like Miss pay every
day I got a weight on the arianna to get
on the bus
and I've extra seven time to be at the
bus stop when I get there and I said
ma'am leave that [ __ ] leave a-- you
leave that [ __ ] she'll get
downtime but you know you you get they
pamper them in my neighborhood I said
don't you dare pamper my black key leave
that [ __ ] cuz I'll leave you ain't you
ain't in the car when I get in the car
[ __ ] bye back my kids no you better get
in the car for mama because she'll leave
you I [ __ ] you to school I mean my
daughter with coming house one time
inside I need you to take me to
Starbucks
I'm like why cool kids coming spoon
Starbucks I said [ __ ] you better go to
school you better I said it's night I
say you crazy if you think I'm gonna get
up
six o'clock in the morning take you to
Starbucks you better take your fat ass
at Starbucks at night and get you a cup
and put you some hot chocolate in the
morning I'm not going I'm not getting up
at no 6 o'clock to make you cool but
they do that right got the status thing
yes sir stated they come bring me my
lunch I left my lunch I tell my kids if
you leave some you didn't [ __ ] won't
cuz I'm in a beer with no wig and no
brought in yesterday [ __ ] I'm not
getting up with the bed last night name
watched it before they come o is
yesterday [ __ ] so I'm not getting up
you crazy saying I'm not nobody nobody
gave me now do they understand that no
one gave you anything
hell yeah they get it they get it yeah
they get it but they like nobody want to
hear y'all your poor story's not true no
that's not true
look here thank you my cable got cut off
one day right so I go in the house on my
cable cut off in that Tim was I like did
you pay the [ __ ] KB miles oh my god I
forgot to pay the cable go turn the
cable before the kids get on I was like
[ __ ] these kids you know how many time I
had to look at a father TV and thought
it was snowing I'm like I'm not going
I'm something going to bed [ __ ] these
kids I don't care about the keys but he
broke his neck payday because he don't
want the kids to ever know what it's
like they not have like gas or [ __ ] TG
they fat they could miss a couple meals
Joe I didn't cut that cable back home
but he probably he did he came home and
cut it all I don't I don't I don't go
out the way for you I love you but I
tell you I don't love you like Jesus do
he loved you on condition I would stay
up this [ __ ] out of you oh I'll own my
kids money you got to pay me back my
daughter call me she said can I borrow
$3,000 I said [ __ ] you got a wrong
number
3,000 yeah at about a cop I don't gonna
do it that she I got my car Joe my car
paid off I Drive a little old last
cruise that McCracken with McCracken
ease left I bought for her that's what I
Drive every day my [ __ ] paid off I'm not
buying you know car but [ __ ] it was on
my phone bill for three years you never
paid the phone bill so how you gonna pay
me back 3,000 Oh what she said that I
call you back
I said this is my money I worked on for
this money I know you was dead when I
was selling crack and forging check but
you had joys and night she